I adamantly did not watch Game of
Thrones okay forever I want to ask you
why I want to you know you fought us so
hard for the last three-plus years
reason when we kept telling y'all ass to
watch Game of Thrones I didn't want to
watch it because he wasn't watch it in
one week because because the because I
watched the few and I actually read the
first book or Marin I can't remember
fire night one or two I can't remember
but it was so long ago because the book
came out a long time ago yeah but when I
was watching this show it just wasn't
that great that's what happens that when
you read the book first it he always
ruins it
hey I'm single I've never seen anything
where I've read the book first and I'm
like ah man yeah and I think it was just
so slow and there was so much thing and
I couldn't remember everything from the
book so I you know it was just like
watching with a fresh pair of eyes right
and then the show takes work though like
you just have to remember everyone's
names like you said they they they take
they have so many new characters they're
introducing all the time yeah so that's
what it was it was Brienne of Tarth it
was this from Targaryen I was like you
know what the [ __ ] there's so many
characters here now you know what names
but the titties made just like so much
Oh titty okay okay let's get back to the
dude with Melisandre the the nicest
titties of all the river service to us
those are her [ __ ] titties
dude you know what I found out that
disappointed me
so throughout though all of the seasons
right now mind you I never got to see
Circe's titties
you know Circe's guy [ __ ] it's a TD
double yes they showed I thought their
shows are luscious titties dude it was
CGI to know that they they have titty
doubles for her to really yeah in the
first episode that was not in the first
episode I think later she it was in a
writer in a later season obviously she's
the one who's most importantly you got
to see Theon's dead didn't you see his
dick Theon's dick I can't remember
though when you guys like a dick cut off
remember before that don't they show his
dick cut off see they didn't actually
shows dude yeah but it was like in the
first season you see the
okay the saddest moment yeah because
they foreshadowed it so early they knew
who's gonna get his dick cut off I saw
when when cuz Tim told me that it wasn't
Circe's actually titties and that made
that scene ten times worse was that's a
shame one yeah shame shame because she's
an older woman but she's [ __ ] fine
dude yeah she's fine as hell but then
her real titties might be disappointing
I know and that those two got luscious
young titties titties there was a good
age to them it is funny because when
when people were trying to get me to
watch the show to telling me the biggest
reason why I should watch it was because
of the titties after a while you just
don't care about them it's all the
reason to watch that show that's what I
like about the show there's there's many
layers right I mean you know you when
you watch content you can watch it for
the titty you can watch it for the
action you go watch her for the drama
you can watch it for it and that's what
makes a good show is because everyone
can enjoy it for different reasons
oh yeah because when I was watching it
all I could think about was after a
while when the story started getting
good around like the second or third
season I was like dude move these
titties out the way let's let's continue
the story yeah yeah like in what a
ballsy move that they killed Ned Stark
in the first season like I thought first
time I saw that I was like this is a
[ __ ] job I knew they were gonna kill
I had no idea
I don't read the books so it was like
and I was like five years late I just
didn't like the very predictable
foreshadowing for example when they had
Daenerys Targaryen in the very first
scene right where her [ __ ] freaky ass
brother takes off her dress is [ __ ] and
this it's that boiling hot water bath
and she steps into it I might buy
something with dragons my dad dragged
yeah yeah she goes over my head I had no
[ __ ] home and I'm not really like
critical like when I watch stuff I don't
critique it at first I never do I just
watched to enjoy it how whoever directs
it wants me to watch it but then there
was a lot of stuff that just kind of
like okay like when they just kept
popping up and it distracted you yeah so
like when they threw the kid over when
they threw bran over I was like he's
gonna throw him out the window
right and he throws him out and
everybody that was so shocking right I
don't think so love
yes I move his character development was
really great because Jaime Lannister I
hated his guts but then you start to
feel bad for him after a while because
he doesn't even want to be considered a
Kingslayer like that that title was
actually something that kind of made him
feel really bad because he lusted for
Cersei yeah so tight and then the other
thing that was the opposite is brans
character development because you
[ __ ] hate him at the end of the
seasons well could he still [ __ ]
worse this was brand right this is this
is if you guys haven't seen the latest
episode this is what this episode is so
shits going down right spoiler alert
shits going down people are dying that
bran goes I'm going to walk everyone's
protecting this is all for you
[ __ ] and then you're ditching
your own birthday party basically yeah
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing he sends the damn clothes out he
goes out and [ __ ] hangs that like he
goes on his drone basically this fool
flies off in his drone to do what I
don't know I everybody get murdered yeah
first hand but then the thing too is
like when I saw him award I was like oh
he's good this is what we've been
waiting for he does something cool that
[ __ ] could at least used the crow to
poke out a [ __ ] White Walkers eye he
was like oh here's the night King and
then that was it that was it he just
does excuse me and he disappears for a
[ __ ] excuse me how were you for six
hours you [ __ ] [ __ ] back but the
theory you brought up today that makes
me think that like it was on purpose
yes I wanna I hope that's what it is if
it's not then they wasted this all this
character for no reason like for him to
have to just warg into the crows and
then that be it I don't know what else
they're gonna do it so for people who
don't know there's a lot of like random
theories that are flowing floating up
and so I kind of googled I forgot what I
googled but it left led to this theory
where there there's a theory that bran
is actually there's two so it kind of
goes hand in hand where they think that
bran is actually the night king because
he can go back in forth and time and so
he was actually confronting himself and
the reason why people think that is
because wouldn't a three-eyed raven is
the night king yeah oh but here's the
weird part and the reason why that kind
of gets debunked it's because you could
actually see this scene where the forest
people they put the dragon class into
that person that wasn't brand yeah but
then he has the
to change the past or whatever to a
certain extent and so what they're
saying is that bran is actually evil and
he was meeting up with the night King
and when he warden to those Ravens he
was actually communicating with the
night king he's for sure evil dude yeah
his sophist Arya was the one that
actually ruined brand's plan because
that wasn't expected that cunning little
[ __ ] good eye you know what was [ __ ]
with everything I forgot because when
you first watch the episode she's ten
years old yeah but I know she had the
scene where she got [ __ ] I was like
look and she looks exactly the same she
looks a little taller yeah she seems
like a little boy but long hair like
what the [ __ ] but then I guess in this
show she's like 22 well what was weird
to me is like she you know how she was
like sexually forward with the dude and
then it just felt like she was just this
jailbait mmm and she's like I'm about to
she was like she I've even though she
was the predator it was just weird she
couldn't wait she said I need some dick
to see how it feels like I did that see
where she's just laying there it like
you could totally see the disappointment
in her face like that was it she's
probably like hmm I probably like there
was a there was a mean that says when
winter came but you didn't this is what
I waited for yeah yeah that's hilarious
that's there's a couple of moments in
this show now mind you because I was I
wasn't against watching as I tried and I
didn't like it but then it was difficult
for you because you couldn't get through
the house slow the first two seasons but
yeah it takes work dude yeah it does you
don't start realizing that you like it
until a couple episodes in yeah if you
do not get to the red wedding and you
are missing out that is one of the most
iconic moments in the whole series
because I've never meant you know what
if you say like look this is gonna be a
bunch of spoilers and if you haven't
seen it it's been out for eight years
you cut back so anyways so [ __ ] I've
never seen somebody put out a scene
where somebody stabs up a fetus pregnant
lady in the study but it was a spirit
fetus so wills okay yeah and then they
showed it to that was like the first
thing they showed it wasn't her just
getting stabbed in the gut and I've
never seen somebody stab somebody that
fast that repeats so much so violent
dude so violent I had nightmares I like
PTSD after watching that that was a
[ __ ] rough episode okay so what do
you think
at the end you know how like the the
[ __ ] red lit like lady she went at
she walked out to the [ __ ] Oh
something that she sacrificed herself to
the Sun God and [ __ ] I think was that
was a good redemption for her well that
was great that [ __ ] I think that was it
was just her job is done now so sure
that I can because I mean [ __ ] is like
3,000 years old you know she's like a
[ __ ] disgusting gremlin [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ] look like [ __ ]
Gollum and [ __ ] like yes I not take the
necklace off that thing was a big
shocker to I was like what does she do
oh my I forgot about home I literally
forgot about her I didn't think she'd be
coming back in the season but she was
hot though yeah I mean it was funny
because when she's walking into the
scene it seems like a white Walker
messengers coming yeah and then it's not
your turn dude should i that's cool
okay I'll just make sure I talk really
close okay thank God your sounds good I
could hear it in here I might I think I
sound low oh I don't know if you yes I
don't know okay
test test test
okay I don't know did I sound regular -
yeah he's ornery okay yeah but yeah the
show has so many twists and turns and I
think you kind of get emotionally
involved with certain characters and
they keep killing them off who did you
think should have died - sad well
[ __ ] start
reveille he [ __ ] you kills no way
he's gonna survive to the end he for
sure sure he is I someone told me the
books are from his point of view
oh that's always the [ __ ] that survived
because he's a Meister get rid of them
yeah he's the [ __ ] Meister that's why
so he's the one useless bro they need
him alive so he could write it all
that's right they should just call it
[ __ ] the well if he's writing the
books then they should just call it by
everybody died because of me why I
didn't do anything to help yeah he does
nothing dude and he keeps holding on to
the fact that he killed a night walker
by chance and then he keeps holding on
to the fact that he killed a [ __ ]
then by chance yeah
the [ __ ] outta get out of here bro you
know it seems to forget I was the first
one to kill a white
my chance you buy you got lucky Sam a
little Gilly cuz even the way he even
had a moment where he quote-unquote
stood up to his dad right so he goes
he's like [ __ ] this thing I'm out of my
dad's castle or whatever he takes the
the the Valyrian steel sword but he has
to do it like a [ __ ] way he does even
his dad hides out in the middle of night
and run I showed him and then when he
finds out that Daenerys killed his
brother and his dad he's like really he
was so polite like it was his fault yeah
I've never seen somebody's lip quiver
for ten minutes it goes up yeah remember
that scene when all is all [ __ ] up and
it's kind of like this montage and you
see him in a body of White Walkers
shivering like a little [ __ ] yep and
I'm like you should have died yeah dude
how did that guy survive everybody got
mad at me on Twitter I was like I
[ __ ] hate Samwell Tarly hate him
what's the yeah I like him cuz I hate
him okay I like him cuz he's such a
little [ __ ] I want to keep him around
to laugh at him I remember earlier in
the seasons I was like why are we going
back to the dude like any time they
would you know it was story Oh rounds
the show so if everyone's a heroic
tough guy or whatever there's no reality
or Norma see so you need that guy to
represent how crazy battles are and all
that that's true there was also this
other theory which was kind of
interesting so you know how it was it
the met I thought nothing man from
nowhere the man with no face right yeah
with this oh yeah the sexy guy for the
long yet so you know you know him right
yeah there's a theory saying that
remember her original dance partner that
the sword guy yeah yeah the curly-haired
flatpoint
they're saying that that is actually
that might actually be the faceless man
that will be so tired because if you
look at that scene so he kicks
everybody's ass right and if you go back
to a scene where you were there talking
about the who's the guy who got his face
burned what's his name
oh that big guy yeah a hound so clicking
Clegane right so the gain so remember
there was a scene where arya was
speaking to Clegane and he was asking
her who's on her list yeah
as she mentions the guy who she
eventually you know gouges his eyes out
and [ __ ] in the brothel but she
mentioned that oh I want to kill the guy
who killed my master and he mentions his
name and then clicking was like him he
sucks like what
[ __ ] like what do you mean like you're
saying your sword master got killed by
bad guy so how was this guy who was like
the best sword guy in all of Westeros
everybody died on purpose they think
that he didn't die just do that was
actually the faceless man and so he
probably escaped but who died them so
that you didn't get to see who died
because she ran away and all you hear is
the fighting so the theory is that that
person is actually the faceless man dude
that'd be tire if they revealed that her
sword teacher yeah yeah because how is
this guy the the man who was the best
swordsman so then when she was at the
monastery the faceless the death
monastery yeah I think that the faceless
man was actually that guy oh yes
something else know this what they're
saying that the teacher was the faceless
man yeah oh yeah b-dawg as they were so
mean yeah you didn't get to see him
actually die you saw him beat everybody
up with that wooden sword and then click
gain actually confirmed that the the
person that she later on killed wasn't
even dope like he was he forgot about
that yeah yeah but I was a [ __ ] she
looked good yeah with a [ __ ] ball
stick did bar was saying that they've
been prepping her to be able to do all
this stuff because they knew first years
ago that she was gonna kill the night
king Wow prepping her so did you guys
love these remember that whole scene
when the red lady was telling her blue
eyes yeah I was like ooh blue eyes I
know she was gonna go kill a bunch of
White Walkers yeah and then I totally
forgot when she came back it was like
all blue eyes I didn't know that until
someone told me that she that's what she
said do you do did you understand the
thing before she was saying like green
eyes brown eyes yeah and in blue eyes
remember that yeah brown eyes is what a
little little finger I'll just say a
little snake yeah right and then green
eyes I think was supposed to be if you
go on Twitter were saying a Circe if you
go on Twitter you can see this clip of
Arya and Brienne of Tarth practicing the
sparring [ __ ] where they were where they
were sparring with in Winterfell where
she did that knife flip as she caught it
as she put it - bro that's [ __ ] clean
dude she actually did in real life where
she does the flip grabs the knife and
put Steward throat damn [ __ ] gangster
dude art is pretty fire D jumper having
sex I don't see that yeah I never want
to see that everyone
she's cute you know how all that one
tough ass [ __ ] that little girl that
got crushed by the giant what's her name
[ __ ] lady more money more money
interesting up in both scenes her and
Aria kind of did the whole same
situation oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they were caught anything [ __ ] hitch
like that dude I thought they were she
was gonna get her face eaten I was like
dude I was covering my eyes like I don't
want to see this I don't wanna see this
do lady Mormont that little girl I
thought she was so doped to the point
she was gonna spin off on her own show
yeah I was thinking they killed her off
she was though some people hate her I
don't a lot of people hate her why
there's a little [ __ ] yeah you know
what who hates her [ __ ] sexist
misogynist that's what they I just like
seeing kids in powerful roles yeah cuz I
mean dad used to happen like you know
like it was a king like a like a kid
king and the dad died or whatever and
it's like now that's that Chinese movie
the [ __ ] Last Emperor what our dad to
check his [ __ ] and all that stuff yeah
but then you get a shot that's that's
that's that's why people don't like kid
kings yeah in this universe is cuz you
look at King Joffrey you're like dude
[ __ ] that guy I was looking at like a
montage of King Joffrey and I was like
do you that because it make you wonder
like why did why does an adult just
[ __ ] slap that fool aside and then
take over it's so easy yeah that's what
they were doing anyways yeah that's true
they were just running in circles well
by actually who so who was who was the
character that you guys hated the most
so far throughout the whole series
oh I would say get all free and a little
bit a little finger only because I
thought he was a good guy and I felt
like he backstab me like I was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ]